désormais même si c'est devenu la
nouvelle application rencontre à la mode
avec les appartements le shopping les
dîners la chaîne semble désormais se
spécialiser dans les rencontres
amoureuses
bienvenue à vous qui aimez les belles
histoires d'amour l'amour est dans le
pré est mariée au premier regard mon
admirateur secret et comme si cela ne
suffisait pas voici maintenant et si on
se rencontrait un tout nouveau format de
plus dès lundi dernier en seconde partie
de soirée sur m6 voici déjà tombés
amoureux sans jamais s'être rencontrés
le principe est simple deux célibataires
qui discute depuis des mois
virtuellement se rencontrent pour la
toute première fois devant les caméras
de l'émission
un concept qui a donné naissance à des
séquences plus ou moins mal éteinte mais
du coup c'est moins marrant en vrai si
pour certains la magie n'a pas opéré
pour d'autres l'expérience a été un
franc succès
[Musique]
l'émission a réuni en moyenne 1,3
million de curieux soit 15,1 % du public
alors ici on se rencontrait sur m6
qu'elle bio pour cette nouvelle émission
de dating
alors pour ce bien se rendre compte de
quoi il s'agit on vous a fait un rose
art fair est extrait rencontre entre
kevin et lucie et à une différence
d'ascq est pas énorme 1 37 ans et 35 ans
et 27 ans pas ouf
mais c'est dans les petits ruisseaux
qu'ont fait les grands fleuves à passer
venu avec moi suzanne j'ai besoin de
réfléchir à kevin chum 3 ou dépourvus
manger non plus c'est l'appel du désir
sous la ve comment je vais me
dépatouiller tout ça je suis pas et je
pense que ça se voit sur ma tête je me
dis ça y est c'est parfait on va pouvoir
dormir ensemble mois passé une bonne
nuit
je pense que donc des années et de la
maturité
donc du coup bah je vais je m'étais
ouais je vais rentrer je suis déçu parce
que j'espérais qu'on est plus loin tous
les deux ensemble et au final à rentrer
chez eux
je pense que kevin je pense que tu as
confondues en fait deux types
d'émissions je sais pas ce que lui pour
si les dents voilà que ça en gros
c'était la télé bing maps ans
christopher obala moi c'est pas ne s'est
pas difficile j'ai détesté de bout en
bout
alors c'est là on est encore passé une
étape on encore plus dans le voyeurisme
dans le manque de pudeur voilà que
maintenant on a des caméras qui vont
donner jusqu'à dans la chambre à coucher
donc voilà j'ai pas nouveau c'est pas
nouveau mais c'est voilà moi je déteste
mais après je comprends m6 qui vous
voilà qui continue sur la carre du
dating parce que ça marche donc bon
qu'ils continuent mais ça sera sans moi
alors nous avons ici une spécialiste des
réseaux sociaux qui s'y connaît très
bien et c'est alors moyens parce que
justement
oui c'est le point zéro c'est moderne ça
change c'est du dating mais c'est
différent pour une fois on voit quelque
chose de différent alors on met on met à
l'antenne des gens qui se parlent et ça
arrive à beaucoup de monde
faut arrêter de notre chantier des
réseaux sociaux pendant des mois des
années
et puis à la première rencontre qu'est
ce qui va se passer moi je pense à
succès c'est drôle on trouve ça super
naturel je trouve sa vraie et
franchement bravo m6 passe quand ils ont
eu une bonne idée ça change moi je
trouve ça super alors le devine à mon
avis non mais vraiment mais pas m6 quoi
c'est insupportable moi j'ai dit l'être
pour cette émission m'a les entend pas
mieux n'y a rien à tamié pas le mal et
l'émission est malaisé 2009 est merdique
ça rejoint totalement ce que je dis
c'est gênant même quand on regarde y'a
rien de drôle je vois jp qui dira oui
c'est jacques est drôle c'est drôle de
regarder les gens s'afficher c'est que
ça marche mais il faut pas il faut pas
être malhonnête les gens qui regardent
sa devancière voyant lui l'a jamais vu à
jamais et c'est exactement cet effet
l'on veut les gens sont tristes vers les
sciences ridicule on regarde les gens
qu'est ce qui marche c'est de la merde
qu'on leur propose
ça me fait rigoler parce que le mec qui
s'attendent à quelque chose à la ligue
c'est pas du tout ma came elle s'en va
moi je trouve que c'est un beau mâle il
faut pas être malhonnête les gens qui
regardent ils regardent aussi pour ça
alors qu'eminem épanouie
honnêtement j'avais je voulais donner sa
chance au produit quand on avait parlé
le jauge est venu extrêmement déçu il a
réussi à aller dans cette émission à
commencer par la voix off qui est
insupportable n'en parle pas les voix de
mayroy il a peur de la différence d'âge
qu'on dirait vous savez les vielles
script reality la vielle gens réagiront
total d'étudiants comédiens mauvais au
possible
c'est franchement c'est absolument pas
moderne justement c'est chouette afin
que la cuisse démissionnaire d'un
scandale j'avais finalement l'émission
y'a digne ali mais alors ça va pas du
tout la gênait pas pour mais alors
pourquoi ça a marché monsieur qui passez
votre chemin
pourquoi ça marche et c'est la nostalgie
des dettes dans des bars mois des débats
informations ces deux occasions c'est
nous poser en terrasse et de voir la
connexion dans les gens et je trouve que
l'émission a bien sûr être capté le gall
exercice fusalp et jusqu'en avril à
d'ailleurs même sens que ça fait plaisir
droits des gens se dire je t'aime alors
sachez mes camarades vous m
[Rires]